alors c'est ça alors c'est ça c'est
réglement de compte OK Corral je trouve
ça personnellement lamentable et ben
arpivo n'aurait jamais fait ça je tiens
à le dire voilà non d'abord parce qu'il
était en direct voilà et que sa meuf est
très jouable
alors maintenant je devais accueillir
monsieur Xavier Couture qui va être sans
doute le nouveau président de canal
jusqu'à ce matin 9h il nous a dit qu'il
venait dans l'émission Ce soir et puis
il a fait appelé par sa secrétaire pour
dire qu'il venait pas donc ça promet
voilà un mec qui tient parole mais je
vais quand même faire l'interview
c'est un garçon fiable je vais quand
même faire l'interview Laurent si vous
voulez faire Xavier Couture
je vais te dire bonsoir donc sauf
scénario à la chaise c'est vous qui vous
retrouverez donc la semaine prochaine à
la tête de Canal+ on va en parler
jusqu'à jusqu'au début de la semaine
vous étiez directeur d'antenne directeur
des sports Directeur des Opérations
Spéciales de TF1 vous avez 50 ans après
les études de médecine de sociologie
vous êtes rentrés comme responsable des
relations publiques chez Thierry Sabine
ensuite l'équipe le sport un quotidien
qui était un énorme échec et qui vous a
retrouvé ruiné
mon pauvre Xavier
enfin bon les gens qui s'étaient abonnés
à l'époque de trouver cette passa
lamentable bien au contraire ça il y
avait une vraie place à l'époque pour un
journal de ce type et j'en avais eu
l'idée avec quelques collaborateurs qui
étaient moins pas au même niveau que moi
et je pense qu'on pourrait ressortir
cette idée c'est pas très bien il faut
bien couture
donc à l'issue de ça vous êtes ruiné
vous entrez à TF1 en 1988 ensuite faites
un passage éclair à la 5 de Berlusconi
le Groupe Export je découvre en même
temps
et vous revenez à TF1 en 1993 exactement
donc vous êtes marié en comment vous
savez tout ça Thierry c'est
les enfants les enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est magnifique merci donc vous êtes
marié Xavier Couture en deuxième noce à
Claire Chazal passionné de golf fan de
BD on dit que c'était un gros gros
flambeur au poker c'est vrai j'aime
beaucoup j'aime beaucoup le poker oui
c'est vrai bien c'est vrai alors publié
chez grassez votre premier roman qui
s'appelle coma vous savez comment on
fait Xavier
de ouf pour essayer
donc vous voulez que je fasse le pitch
oui
simplement c'est la première fois que je
le vois dans le commerce je pourrais
jeter un œil sur mon livre
j'adore ce que je fais apparemment quand
on lit on voit que c'est vous qui l'avez
écrit quand même j'ai pas eu de gens
donc voilà le narrateur s'appelle
Mathieu il est peintre homosexuel et il
est fils de Sophie Kléber qui est une
actrice de renommée internationale en
Sophie Kléber Sophie Marceau bien sûr
vous avez compris
c'est un roman il faut le savoir et les
gens qui pensent
tout commence par la une d'un magazine
qui s'appelle primo un magazine à
scandale qui sort le lundi matin et
quand Sophie Kléber voit la une de ce
magazine primo elle reconnaît son mari
et son fils enlacé dans une position
sans équivoque aucune la phrase exacte
est sans équivoque aucune voilà
donc elle voit son fils Mathieu je me
suis cassé le cul à écrire ça j'aimerais
bien qu'on s'y est exactement elle voit
son fils Mathieu donc avec son beau-père
évidemment enlacé et en voyant ça
tellement décontenancé que elle est
fauchée par un autobus et vous dites
d'ailleurs tu ne les plus belles phrases
du livre ça peut être violent un autobus
si vous voulez
pas mal bien sûr parce que il y a
plusieurs il y a plusieurs degrés de
lecture et je crois que c'est ça aussi
l'école de la vie quand on voit à
l'autobus à l'arrêt on ne se rend pas
compte
voilà donc elle est fauchée par un
autobus parce que c'est violent en
autobus si elle tombe dans le coma et
pour se venger Matthieu le fils de
Sophie Kléber donc va se castrer le
rédacteur en chef de Primo grande pour
obtenir une confession écrite de la part
de ce rédacteur en chef sur les méthodes
de la presse à scandale voilà mais tout
va déraper la vengeance tourner au drame
face à un livre très violent oui oui
très violent
cette presse que vous connaissez bien
Thierry oui bien sûr mais il y a une
scène où ah oui il y a une chanson
de Primo c'est très très violent vous
parlez de l'anatomie de l'abjection
contemporaine c'est une belle phrase
qu'un pote à moi m'a vendu je l'ai
replacé je l'aime bien cette phrase je
pense qu'elle résume bien la situation
elle est à peu prétentieuse ce qui est à
mon image et pourquoi pas littéraire et
je la revendique cette phrase j'aime
beaucoup alors ce qui vous a conduit à
écrire ce livre Xavier c'est d'avoir
fait l'expérience d'être un people livré
le paparazzi voilà les aventures je
voulais appeler ça les aventures de
Mario les people et puis je me suis dit
non coma coma c'est bien comme c'est du
emblématique de la chaîne pour laquelle
j'ai travaillé il y a encore peu de
temps et non c'est un bon titre déconne
pas ils vont te prendre un canal comme
PDG c'est mieux que lui bien et alors
Xavier sérieusement en épousant le
Claire Chazal vous saviez bien que vous
seriez livré au paparazzi oui mais oui
le but premier n'était pas de l'épouser
le but premier de la pécho
et comme je me suis fait
un peu voler j'étais obligé de réparer
comme on disait au 19e siècle voilà
parce que vous avez fait un mariage sur
médiatisé avec le Tout-Paris alors c'est
très marrant parce que vous avez renâclé
à poser devant l'église il a fallu vous
supplier vous acceptiez de faire des
photos devant l'église le contrat
c'était pas signé en fait les photos
près de l'hôtel de vente derrière
l'hôtel étaient vendu à Paris Match et
on les a vu dans Paris Match la semaine
suivante Xavier oui mais ça c'était pour
échapper à d'autres paparazzi quoi vous
savez ce qu'il faut il faut livrer un
peu il faut se livrer à un journal pour
éviter
alors quand Claire Chazal publie son
deuxième roman vous êtes une serrée une
série qu'on l'a fait des radios
vous êtes une série qu'on a fasse passer
pour une imbécile alors qu'elle a fait
HEC vous dites mais bien sûr
elle est extrêmement brillante je
n'aurais pas épousé une imbécile les
gens qui me connaissent le savent bien
sûr alors il y a autre chose qui vous
insulte aussi c'est la publication par
voici des confidences de votre première
femme
où elle raconte comment son mariage à
elle a été détruit par Claire Chazal ça
vous a bien énervé ça aussi Xavier c'est
la vie privée on n'a pas le droit on a
pas le droit d'être allé ça comme ça
voilà je crois que Claire Chazal est en
pour parler pour vendre notre
correspondance en ce moment là et là
alors plutôt que de tabasser les gens
qui écrivaient des articles dans Voici
contre Claire Chazal comme bec BD ou des
articles sur votre vie privée comme
Jacques Colas
vous décidez d'écrire d'écrire un livre
donc ce livre commun comment elle était
accueillie par la critique Xavier mais
écoutez ce livre a été plutôt bien
accueilli par la critique parce que
au-delà du règlement de compte il faut y
voir une véritable œuvre littéraire je
ne découvre pas je ne découvrais pas la
littérature je suis quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup de talent je ne serai pas à la
place que que je cube je n'aurais pas
cette place je n'ai pas assez de verre
cette faconde et puis cette puissance
littéraire et et je pense que c'est un
livre qui restera vous savez il y a des
livres qui passent
il y a des livres qui restent je pense
que mon livre
restera alors évidemment
Frédéric BD une fois plus c'est montré
très très critique à votre endroit comme
il l'avait été envers Claire Chazal
quand elle est publiée c'est bouquins
c'est lui qui a remarqué cette phrase un
bus c'est violent c'est lui qui l'a
remarqué le premier il a remarqué aussi
que dans les trois premières lignes et
Xavier il y avait deux fois le mot
rester oui parce que rester une fois
c'est bien mais restez deux fois c'est
quand même on reste plus quoi c'est ça
il y a la force du verbe rester quand on
reste deux fois et re restez c'était pas
joli non j'ai préféré écrire deux fois
reste mais dites-moi vous l'avez relu ce
livre et bien oui je l'ai relu ce livre
et je l'ai trouvé formidable c'est pas
seulement libre à clé c'est un livre
émouvant c'est un livre encore une fois
très bien écrit remarque quelques
phrases comme tu patauge mais que tu
patauge j'aime bien oui vous savez la
force des gens qui répètent ça c'est
enfonce le clou beaucoup trop Gali qui
patauge tu patauge
il y a une belle phrase dans le livre
c'est les malfrats sont souvent les
premières revendiquer la morale on
revendique ce qu'on a pas on pourrait
vous l'appliquer d'une certaine façon
j'étais sûr que vous alliez citer cette
phrase à mettre en exerg c'est vrai
qu'elle représente assez bien ce que ce
que j'ai accompli dans mon travail c'est
ces dernières années c'est vrai qu'on
est toujours le malfrat de l'eau et
quelque part je me suis embarqué dans
une phrase que je suis incapable de
terminer c'est la raison pour laquelle
je préfère écrire parce que ça mérite
mais dites-moi Xavier honnêtement
ce que vous trouvez le plus amoral un
moral aussi la moutarde peut-être c'est
que vous trouvez le plus amoral c'est le
c'est le fils qui couche avec le mari de
sa mère ou les paparazzis qui les
photographies c'est le paparazzi qui les
photographies qui est sale c'est lui qui
fait caca ou celui qui prend la photo
mais comme marrant quand on a bossé sur
TF1 quand on a été directeur d'antenne
d'attaquer le voyeurisme parce que TF1
c'est quand même la chaîne de Star
Academy Arthur
bonjour rêve d'un jour pardon d'Arthur
aussi vis ma vie c'est comme cette
chaîne là non bien sûr
mais parce que vous confondez voyeurisme
et qualité et nous on a une mission on a
une mission artistique sur cette chaîne
et il y a plusieurs degrés de lecture
encore une fois voilà ce que vous
appelez vous voyez au risque c'est quand
même des des émissions qui resteront des
programmes forts qui auront marquer la
décennie alors bientôt il y a un nouveau
programme sur TF1 vous ne serez plus là
Xavier évidemment c'est Temptation
Island ou donc on essaie de détruire des
couples c'est bon on réfléchit beaucoup
on a quand même on fait des
brainstormings on s'est dit une île les
gens ne peuvent pas s'enfuir donc si on
laisse des gens mais attention c'est un
panel de cette étudié on n'est pas des
personnes au hasard on il y a un vrai
casting
oui oui des [ __ ] mais pas que des [ __ ]
il y a des gros cons il y a des racistes
quand même que le spectateurs
alors bon la critique a pas été tendre
avec vous Xavier il faut bien le dire on
ne fait pas cette télé pour les
critiques je vous le rappelle mais pour
les gens qui regardent non mais pour
votre livre pour votre livre la critique
a pas été très tendre avec vous non plus
alors on aurait pu compter sur le
soutien de la chaîne preuve d'avoir vous
a invité dans son émission qui s'appelle
vol de nuit parce que le passe au petit
matin et donc on vous a coupé au montage
donc on vous voit dans l'émission
sourire comme ça de temps en temps mais
votre interview a été coupé par la vie
était tronqué mon interview était saboté
caviardée et je trouve ça scandaleux de
la part de PPDA qui se dit être un
journaliste intègre c'est peut-être ce
que j'ai tiré sa meuf alors Monsieur
alors c'est ça alors c'est ça c'est
réglement de compte OK Corral je trouve
ça personnellement lamentable et ben
harpivo n'aurait jamais fait ça je tiens
à le dire voilà non d'abord parce qu'il
était en direct voilà et que la meuf est
injouable
alors vous avez dit que Xavier au sujet
de Patrick leulet il choisit ses amis
avec parcimonie et moi en fait je n'en
fais pas partie voilà tout votre
problème quoi je crois non oui c'est
vrai il est très difficile de faire
partie du sérail de Patrick lelec qui
est un être extrêmement sensible bon
très combien de fois dans la
conversation ce mec-là va être au bord
des larmes toujours et bon moi je suis
un petit peu trop dur pour lui un petit
peu trop voilà c'est ça alors on va
parler maintenant donc de TF1 et de
Canal+ interview vérité
[Applaudissements]
alors Xavier Couture d'après le journal
Le Monde vous n'aviez pas prévenu
Étienne Mougeotte donc j'y tiens des
plus proches collaborateurs de votre
nomination à la tête de Canal+ c'est
vrai oui c'est vrai mais vous savez ce
que c'est Thierry on a toujours
différents
donc c'est vrai mais est-ce que le lait
est moujote savait que depuis deux ans
vous aviez des discussions avec
Jean-Marie Messier d'abord pour
remplacer Michel Denisot ensuite pour
prendre la direction du pôle production
c'est un petit métier je crois que tout
se sait et chacun
profite bénéficie des appels d'offres et
chaque année je pense qu'on est tous sur
le marché et que chacun a des connexions
avec les autres chaînes vous savez de
quoi on parle Thierry puisque vous-même
on vous voit régulièrement sur Teva ou
des fois et puis vous étions pour parler
avec la une aussi absolument c'est vrai
et voilà bien vous connaissez Pierre
Lescure oui je les connais oui oui un
ami à vous chez quelqu'un que j'apprécie
c'est quelqu'un qui qui sait partir la
tête haute sans stock-up Shun et je lui
dis bravo
est-ce que Jean-Marie Messine vous a pas
choisi un petit peu par défaut
finalement parce qu'on dit que vous avez
pas la carrure du poste on dit beaucoup
de gens dans le métier disent c'est pas
un XXL quoi couture
non Jean-Marie de Messier
a besoin de résultats il a des
actionnaires qui lui demandent des
comptes et je remercie a besoin de de
personnes qui savent faire rentrer des
sous dans la dans la caisse le financier
c'est pas trop votre domaine on se
souvient de de du sport excusez-moi d'en
reparler mais enfin le quotidien le
sport qui était quand même un échec
financier grave et en artistique ça va
être très difficile pour vous Xavier
parce qu'on interne les gens comme
Farrugia chaba Gaccio vont sans doute
partir le personnel est remonté les
syndicats monsieur Cholet le responsable
de la CFDT a dit je promets à Xavier
Couture des jours difficiles
les gens d'extérieur aussi des gens
comme Jamel des gens comme decones
beaucoup d'artistes vont pas vouloir
travailler pour vous vous allez gérer ça
comment mais on va gérer ça très bien
puisqu'on n'a pas besoin d'artistes sur
Canal+ puisqu'il n'y a pas d'artistique
et qu'on n'est pas concerné par
l'artistique on a simplement des
annonceurs on va faire rentrer donc des
des recettes on va mettre beaucoup
d'écran et on va mettre des films et du
foot je ne vois pas où est la place de
l'artistique là-dedans puisque le film
qu'on achète il a déjà été ouais
et travailler par des artistes d'accord
oui c'est vous êtes vachement
intelligent bah c'est logique enfin il
faudra être con pour pas comprendre ça
j'ai commencé par contre
alors bien sûr vous allez tenter de
rassurer tout le monde Xavier c'est
normal le milieu du cinéma en leur
promettant vous continuerez à leur
donner ce que Canal+ leur donne chaque
année bien sûr même si Messier veut la
fin de l'exception culturelle française
il l'a dit hein rassurer de [ __ ] tout
le monde toujours dans l'ordre vous
pouvez pas arriver en étant tout le
monde
est-ce que Jean-Marie Messi Xavier vous
aurez pas engagé pour faire le sale
boulot finalement pour virer tout le
monde on a dit ça de dubrunny c'est
ensuite de beaucoup de personnes je
crois que le sale boulot est beaucoup
été fait à Canal et à part deux
techniciens de surface il restait plus
grand monde à virer et maintenant voilà
le seul boulot a été fait vous avez
confiance en Jean-Marie Messier
bien sûr je peux faire que confiance à
quelqu'un qui m'a embauché et qui a eu
la finesse de sentir en moi la personne
idéale pour redresser la barre du bateau
Canal+ qui est en train de couler avec
des trublions comme Alain Chabat Jamel
enfin c'est
Dominique Farrugia non mais vous en
voulez plus de ces gens là mérite la
fausse commune
et que Jean-Marie Messier soit débarqué
je vous demande de vous arrêter
imaginez imaginez
Xavier que Jean-Marie Messier soit
débarqué mercredi et qui soit plus
patron de Vivendi Universal vous avez
quitté TF1 vous n'irez pas sur Canal
vous allez être comment un petit peu
Nick ridicule ridicule je l'ai déjà été
donc j'assumerai vous savez ce sera pas
la première fois je serais ridicule et
voilà quoi au chômage et Xavier oui bien
sûr mais moi je suis un battant je pars
je pars battant moi je vais je vais
gagner ce match bien sûr vous êtes
courageux je suis très courageux la
preuve c'est que vous êtes venu ici ce
soir et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu